because I know my parents obviously have
been working hard to make sure that I do
better than them whatever doing better
means but I know that I sit down and
think about well what if there are
certain things that I value differently
than they they do so then like my
definition of better change is like does
that get accounted and like the data
that if someone chooses to do X with
their life that counts a success because
their parents made it possible for them
to have a choice you know I don't
necessarily know if upward mobility sort
of I mean I guess stereotypically it has
a lot to do with sort of like you know
where you're from but I think it
definitely is on a case-to-case basis
for some folks they're not even
necessarily worried about a tangible
side of success whatever the definition
might be money whatever property
education they're like more focused on
how quickly they can get to a point of
seeming or looking success yeah if you
are Google does your name come up I
guess I guess it offends my my mother
was incarcerated when I was 12
and my father raised me I guess I never
never had to worry too much about their
necessities and anything like that wrote
thankful for that I came home and I knew
there was gonna be food in the fridge my
father had his first kid at 16 so I
think his priorities at 23 having then I
think two children and a wife were
providing for a family I guess we
definitely think of you know providing
for one another but it's also just work
and we work together so I think it's
funny I mean cuz that when my dad it was
about 22 or 23 when he came to America I
get started like school and like you
know working it's very to say that his
priorities
we're very different that my parties
were like our know our to choose to be
honest that's not it's not plausible it
doesn't make any sense outside of a
certain type of motor thought I think
exposure is the largest factor in
mobility because if you're just if
you're exposed to certain things and
you're exposed to how to achieve them be
it internships urges mentors or
something like that or your parents then
you have a better chance of achieving it
when you're a kid like some other kid on
the playground that's some cool trick
and everyone's amazed and then they show
how how they did it
it's so simple everyone starts to do
right so it's still amazing but now
everyone else also knows how to do this
amazing thing right it's so then
everybody's like you know like the water
rises for all the boats in the shore
my dad always tell me that he was like
you know you going to college your
children will be better off mmm you're
not gonna be the one you're like the
first generation my kids will be the
ones with like the easy
they will benefit on everything our
parents yeah so it's a matter of what I
do at this point
you